money is the most important thing in the
world it dictates everything around us
it dictates individual freedom how free
and flexible are you to move out of bad
situations or dangerous situations or
feel safe or insecure
and so once people start to feel liberty
and freedom with their money then they
go well why are drugs legal why
why are you taxing me this much why are
x y or z i mean
the automatic withholding
from w2s
is incredible i mean it's the that is
one of the greatest
experience
things that the irs came up with ever
because then you don't even notice the
taxes coming out of your paycheck versus
you cutting the check
and sending it to them they just
automatically withhold that those taxes
that you owe
with your employer and you don't even
notice how bad it is because you're just
like oh here's my net paycheck what gets
in my bank account and that can pay my
bills but you don't look at the gross
value where you're like whoa
i'm losing like half my money because i
live in california i mean i lose like
almost half my money to taxes and i'm
like what did i get for that so i think
that bitcoin is the inception point
where bitcoin starts to challenge
people's beliefs over what government
should control in your life starts with
money then it permeates to everything
else